[Music]
well hello dear friends Welcome to our
program I'd like to know which is a
question and answer program sponsored by
Secrets unsealed in Su TV where you send
us your questions and we answer those
questions on air uh let me just mention
that um many questions we don't answer
immediately because we put them in the
order in which they're received and we
have so many questions that come in uh
if you do have a question however be
patient and send it to us the electronic
address where you can send it you'll see
it on the screen is TV Su tv.org once
again TVM
tv.org we love this program not only
because we are able to answer questions
that people have in their minds and
hearts but also because it forces us to
do research and find answers to
questions that perhaps we've never asked
before and questions that U have maybe
even confused Us in the course of our
lives so uh we love this program and we
trust that you love it as well and that
you will contribute by sending your
questions to us uh also I want to appeal
to you to continue supporting Secrets
unsealed in some TV with your prayers
and with your financial support we could
never do anything that that we do
without your prayers and without your
financial support I have with me today
uh two individuals that I greatly
respect students of the Bible we have uh
Pastor Daniel Miranda a good friend uh
used to work here full-time at Secrets
unsealed uh now is pastor of Fresno
Central Church which means he's still in
the realm and he can still help us amen
and we appreciate his scholarship and
his humility and his willingness to uh
share uh in our program and with us
thank you for coming thank you Pastor
bore it's good to be here with you and
Pastor Salasar in this program and we
have um my good friend Pastor David
Salazar he's made my workload a lot
lighter amen I used to do all the
Spanish my myself and now he's the
coordinator of our Spanish work and he
does I'd like to know he preaches uh he
makes contact with Costa Rica where we
broadcasting I mean he's he's like a
right-hand man amen and thank you for
being with us thank you Pastor it's an
honor and a privilege to work and to be
with Pastor Danielle and with you of
course in this beautiful program which I
know many people watch and is our
favorite for the most part for for the
fact that we can study and actually
learn together from the word of God and
by the way we love Kelly too oh thank
you you know they have a newborn little
Abigail and Kelly works here at Secrets
unsealed phenomenal editor stickler for
details does incredible work amen and
Pastor Salazar's wife does many things
for us his daughters seeing here I mean
we have God's blessing here with uh with
these two men of God and their families
okay enough with the accolades now let's
go Amen to our questions but before we
do we want to have a word of prayer uh
so Pastor Miranda would you pray for us
please
yes let us pray heavenly father thank
you for this program I'd like to know as
Pastor bour mentioned we are blessed to
go deeper into the word of God trying to
find answers to these questions and as
we open your word we play we pray for
the guidance and the direction of your
Holy Spirit Spirit we do not have the
wisdom to answer these questions the
wisdom only comes from you through your
word amen I pray that those who are
watching may be blessed by this program
we pray all this in the name of Jesus
amen amen
amen okay we have a question from Oxnard
California uh kind of in the
neighborhood and the question is this I
have come across dozens of videos on
YouTube be careful what you watch on
YouTube okay where the presenter claims
that tithing does not apply to us today
they State there is no biblical command
for us to pay
tithe Jesus did not command it nor the
apostles further the tithing in the Old
Testament was of cattle and other
agricultural goods and if you bring up
Malachi they say Malachi only applied to
the nation of
Israel with that kind kind of argument
you could say none of the Old Testament
applies to us but that's a subject for
another time I guess simply put they
assert there is no biblical evidence for
us to pay a tithe how would you counter
their
arguments good question good question
yes well certain things are not
specifically commanded in the New
Testament because they were taken for
granted mhm it was a common practice
that there was no necessity of saying
again a new command to do it uh but we
do have
the certainty that if there is no
command specific command and clear
command to
prohibited then it's still binding how
do we know that well circumcision that's
very clear Paul says you know that is
not necessary circumcision or no
circumcision does not Avail anything
right and we find the same thing with
other things which were part of the
Jewish ceremonial of the temple
sacrificial sacrificial system exactly
now when it comes to
tithing even though we do not have a
specific verse in the New Testament that
says you will tithe the tenth of your
increase but we do find references for
example Matthew 23 M um even though
Jesus's purpose here was not exactly
this this is the woes upon the scribes
and
Pharisees yet we find that in Jesus's
mind tithing was still binding he didn't
come to do away with that he says well
to the scribes and Pharisees Hypocrites
for you pay tithe of mint and anes and c
and have neglected the weightier matters
of the law Justice and mercy and Faith
these you ought to have done without
leaving the others undone so is Jesus
here saying that we should not tithe
no the problem here was that some were
majoring in
minors um they were very meticulous with
their ties but they were leaving out the
most important matter so Jesus is saying
do this and do that as well he was
condemning legalism legalism EX in other
words tithing to earn God's favor and
there are many people today that do the
same thing exactly they say you know I
returned the tithe and God promises that
he's going to prosper me well that's
that's not the the best reason the best
reason is I tithe because I'm honest
because it belongs to God and not
tithing is stealing in the same chapter
Pastor you know actually the very
beginning Christ says the following so
that we can understand he says to the
disciples and to the multitude verse 2
and three the scribes and the Pharisees
sit in Moses seat they are actually you
know telling the law teaching the law
and he says all therefore whatsoever
they bite your serve that observe and do
so he's actually saying what they teach
you according to the law of Moses that
is binding that is necessary to do
including Tiding but do not ye after
their works for they say and do not so
he was telling the disciples and the
people before he tell them about you
know what they we're doing wrong and
showing them their legalistic approach
he was saying to them what they're
actually saying according to the law of
of of the word of God that is something
that's still biting you have to do that
so he believed in tithing absolutely the
Lord believed in that institution of
supporting the church and the well in
that case the temple but later will be
the church through that system of Tiding
and offering exactly uh it was never
taken away and Christ never said stop
with that aspect because it's really an
as way to believe and trust in the Lord
It's a relationship of trust in God and
returning to him what is his you know is
a symbol of allegiance of believing in
the Lord in a personal way it seems like
any anything that requires a sacrifice
uh was nailed to the cross according to
many you know we don't have to keep the
Sabbath anymore that was for the Jews
and we don't have to stop eating pork
and some other things that are
detrimental to our health because that
was for the Jews and we don't have to
tithe because because that was for the
Jews so everything is
excused by saying that it was for the
Jews did the Apostle Paul measure in on
this issue of uh returning a tithe yeah
he actually did in 1 Corinthians chapter
9 for
example uh he refers to a scripture in
the Old Testament um quoting from
Deuteronomy
25:4 I'm going to read how Paul quotes
it verses 8 and N of First Corinthians 9
do do I say these things as a mere man
or does not the law say the same also
for it is written in the law of Moses
you shall not muscle an ox while it
Treads out the grain is is it oxen God
is concerned about or does it also say
it for our sakes now let's jump to verse
uh 13 and
14 do you not know that those who
Minister the holy things eat of the
things of the temple and those who serve
at the altar partake of the offerings of
the altar talk about talking about the
priest priest and the Levites and the
Levites correct even so the Lord has
commanded now this sounds like a command
to me mhm that those who preach the
gospel should live from the gospel M and
why don't you muzzle an ax because the
ax the ax is working right so you know
if you work you got to eat correct
correct so um so you know the Apostle
Paul I believe makes it very clear that
those who are preaching the gospel
should live of the Gospel just like The
Oxen you don't muzzle them because they
need to live by uh the grain that
they're treading correct and U and so
and then there's also uh Hebrews chapter
7 uh what we can can we say about the
tithe that was given to mkis by Abraham
does that have anything to do with
tithing these days so before we go to
Hebrews 7 I have one more comment uh
some people might argue with that with
that text uh that we quoted from or Paul
quotes from the Old Testament well
that's referring to offerings or to just
donations but he CL it again in 1
Timothy 5 even more explicit and now
here's talking about the elders and it
says in verse 17 let the elders who rule
well be counted worthy of double honor
and now contextually here the double
honor is the tithe especially those who
labor in the word of on Doctrine for the
scripture says again he quotes the same
verse you shall not muszle an ox while
it Treads out the Grain and now he adds
one more thing that is not mentioned in
1 Corinthians 99 the laborer is worthy
of his wages MH so this is clearly tithe
money yeah and
tithing is actually an
investment yes because because what is
the tithe used for to remunerate the
pastors who work full-time and what do
the pastors do they minister to the
congregation they dedicate babies they
baptize people they teach people how to
give Bible studies uh they they uh do
funerals and everything so the tithe
that is returned that is used to
remunerate the pastors comes back to the
members in services rendered by the
pastor right and so tithing is not only
a matter of
honesty it's also an investment Amen in
the sense that it returns to us in the
services that are offered by the pastor
who is remunerated by the tithe
absolutely I mean it's it's a matter of
the heart of the principle of
where is your affection uh Christ
mentions in Matthew 6 19- 21 speaking of
laying up Treasures in Heaven and then
he kind of says for where your treasure
is there will your heart be also so if
you
have uh your heart is with the Lord
You're Gonna Delight in providing to the
growth of God's work in in on Earth you
will be rejoicing that you can
contribute with your tithes and
offerings not just the tithing but the
offerings aspect also that you can be
generous with them and you will Delight
in seeing God's work expand and continue
and be able to reach to many people
around the world that still have not
heard of The Gospel so it's it's sort of
a a a test of where your affection is if
you love the Lord with your heart you
will have no problem no issue with
Tiding and offering you'll be like this
is the least I can do as you mentioned
Pastor what you receive in return is so
much more the you know you're supposed
to receive mental spiritual and uh food
that will help you spiritually to grow
mental uh spiritual aspects that will
help you understand better the
scriptures and so this is why God
established this system to sustain
ministers teachers Elders that will help
uh the congregations and help them grow
well we can never out
outg Give the Lord can we no so some
mere
pittance it's it's a token really yes uh
so Hebrews chapter 7 Hebrews chapter 7
yes Hebrews chapter 7:8 um the author of
Hebrews is making an argument here um
about how melkisedek is greater than
Abraham but than than Levi because even
Levi paid tithes to melkisedek while he
was still in neighbor loins that's the
argument but the point here that is
concerning to our study in verse 8 it
says here mortal men receive tithes but
there he receives them of whom it is
witness that he lives so the point here
is that by the time Paul wrote the book
of Hebrews he says here men receive ties
so even when the book of Hebrews was
written men were still receiving tithes
and who who is the tithe being returned
to in the Old Testament it was
melkisedek but the argument is that in
the book of Hebrews the tithe is return
to the Lord exactly to Jesus amen is the
parallel that's being drawn here amen so
when we tithe we're not tithing to the
church technically speaking we're
tithing to the Lord amen another so that
the church can carry forward its work
and just another I'm sorry another point
is that the Tiding as you can see
predates the Jewish system mhm you know
it's not just for the Jews it predates
that yes Abraham gave tithe to
melkisedek which predated everybody in
you know in the in the levitical line so
this is why it's important to know that
Tiding it's a principle yes established
before there were any Jews and it was
established for the the benefit of The
Giver more than the receiver really yeah
and the principle and the principle is
the tenth of our increase that belongs
to God's stewardship so it doesn't
matter if it is cattle as it was
mentioned here in the question yeah it's
the tent that's what they were giving
because that's what they had yeah but
today we earn money and we return money
to the Lord the tent that passes under
the rod is the expression that is used
in Leviticus uh and also in the book of
numbers correct um you know it's
interesting the Sabbath predates the
Jews right so Sabbath is before sin in
Genesis mhm clean and unclean animals
they predates Israel absolutely because
Noah took into the ark clean and unclean
and the tithe predates Israel so it's
part of God's original pre- Israel plan
amen and those who say that it isn't
they simply want to keep the money to
themselves and you know they want to
have all seven days for themselves and
they want to uh they want to Delight the
pallet with that which God has forbidden
in other words they think that uh prayer
blesses that which God has
cursed okay very good excellent question
and good answers
gentlemen um let's go to our next
question uh this one comes from Puerto
Rico
Eno been there many times very fervent
members and uh this question comes from
yel uh here here's the question we've
been taught that the Sabbath is a day to
be with God God and that uh all three
letters are capital and the family I
want to know what is the balance there
should be how to determine that that
determine the balance between God and
the family I've heard of families that
instead of going to the church they
decide to go to the beach others even
decide to celebrate kin anos in other
words in in the United States at Sweet
16 in Latin American countries that they
celebrate in a special way the 15th
birthday girls uh so it says others even
decide to celebrate k
kinos um and on the Sabbath I've heard
that it is okay to play games with the
family in the on the Sabbath and I
suppose they leave aside religious and
spiritual things or what about churches
organizing goofy games and sports on the
Sabbath to bring together families and
pray before and after after playing this
is all confusing what's the correct and
true way of approaching this matter
without being legalistic but celebrating
the Sabbath the right way what are the
limits that families and groups of
people should take into consideration
when deciding to have fun in quotation
marks and wanting to in quotation marks
once again feel happy together on the
Sabbath so it has to do with the manner
of observing the Sabbath uh what can we
say about
this well there's a lot of we could say
in a sense of you know what the Bible
speaks of what the Sabbath is for the
Sabbath was made for men and sometimes
we I think that some people are taking
this idea it was made for man so let me
do what I please absolutely that's not
the case it was uh it's a a day that the
Lord Sanctified set aside made it a
point for him to connect with his people
the
emphasis that we are to to have when we
come to the Sabbath is that we rest from
our labors we rest from the cares of the
world the rest of the our obligations
and we Delight to do what pleases in the
eyes of God and spending time with
family it's important within the margins
of using the time to connect them and
uplift them to the Lord so they can
receive a connection with God so you can
spend time in Bible study you can spend
time in nature nature is an actual
textbook of the Lord so you can take
your family nature if necessary but I
have a problem I mean some of these
things that are happening and I
understand Puerto Rico being an island
is you know people say let's go to the
beach and if it's a beach that is you
know desolate or or really you enjoy
nature you can walk in the sand and and
see what the Lord has done it's
beautiful but if you go to the beach and
there's music the people are not dressed
in a way that pleases God you know and
it will distract with what they're doing
it doesn't make sense it's really taken
away from the blessing of connecting
with God and put it more in a
entertainment type of way so I believe
that you know there is not um and maybe
this will take more of a a study and an
actual maybe a sermon or two in regards
to what's truly correct in the Sabbath
but I believe that if we look at the
Bible and we look at the way that God
established the principles of what it
means to spend time with him and not to
do our own will not to do our own thing
our own thinking or likeness but to
relight in him we will find the Sabbath
to be a a true moment of of of unity and
communion with the family I mean I spend
time with my my family when the girls
they actually enjoy a lot more when we
spend morning in the church and then we
can spend the afternoon walking or going
through nature and and they really we
know we benefit all of us together by
that experience but I do believe that
Bible speaks that we should not neglect
assembly so we are to go to church I
believe that's a very important thing
and uh and then add to that experiences
what you can do with family that connect
them to God and to the Bible to the word
of God not away from that you know when
I was four years old my parents accepted
a call uh to go to Colombia as
missionaries and uh we lived uh two
blocks from the ocean
there in kahena WoW on the coast
Atlantic coast of columia and uh one of
our favorite things that we really look
forward to was going to the beach on
Sabbath afternoon after the worship
service to search for shells there were
beautiful shells and our parents would
take advantage of teaching us spiritual
lessons uh but it's different to go to
the beach to go swimming on Sabbath and
to just horse around and you know to
play and you know maybe maybe take a
ball and kick the ball around uh you
know that's a different story because
there's really no connection with God it
is a secular Endeavor on the Sabbath yes
well the Bible is clear in Isaiah
58:13 gives us some principles about
Sabbath keeping and it says if you turn
away your fruit from the sa your food
from the Sabbath from doing your own
pleasure on my holy day and call the
Sabbath of delight the holy day of the
Lord honorable and shall honor him not
doing your own ways not finding your own
pleasure not speaking your own words so
though I believe that every now and then
if you're so burdened and you want to
spend some time in nature and spend the
Sabbath in nature that's fine with that
spiritual purpose if you do this all the
time then as you said we need assembly
but other things like the ones mentioned
in this question I believe they go
against the principle that we find in
the word of God doing our own pleasure
let's lift those things for other days
yeah not for the Sabbath the the Bible
speaks in principles MH we don't have
lists of dos and don'ts on the Sabbath
when you read Isaiah 58 you have to be
honest and
sincere because it's very easy to
rationalize and say well that's not my
will that's not speaking my own words be
honest with yourself is what you're
doing centered only on God are you
suspending what you regularly do so you
can worship God and Center only on him
God bless hope to see you next
[Music]
time